if you have a condition in your neck
that puts pressure on your spinal cord
or spinal nerves your doctor may
recommend a posterior cervical
laminectomy and fusion the spine in your
neck also called the cervical spine has
7 Bones called vertebrae the front part
of each vertebra is called the vertebral
body except for the first vertebra
between most vertebrae is a soft cushion
of cartilage called an intervertebral
disc
the back part of each vertebra has a
curved section called the vertebral arch
except for the first vertebra each
vertebral arch has a bony projection
called the spinous process
on each side of the spinous process is a
flat piece of bone called a lamina the
vertebral arch of the vertebra surrounds
and protects your spinal cord
a column of nervous tissue connecting
your brain to other nerves in your body
your spinal cord passes through an
enclosed space called the vertebral
canal which is formed by the vertebral
arches of your vertebrae
over time your cervical spine may
develop problems such as a shrinking
disc
a herniated or ruptured disc
or bony growths on your vertebrae called
bone spurs
these changes can narrow your vertebral
canal and put pressure on your spinal
cord or the nerves that branch off of it
the pressure can cause neck pain and
stiffness or pain numbness and weakness
in your arms or hands
before your procedure an intravenous
line or IV will be started
you may be given antibiotics through the
IV to decrease your chance of infection
you will be given general anesthesia to
make you unconscious and pain-free
during the procedure a breathing tube
will be inserted through your mouth and
down your throat to help you breathe
during the operation
your surgeon will make an incision on
the back of your neck the laminae of the
affected vertebrae will be exposed the
spinous processes and laminae will be
removed from the affected vertebrae to
relieve the pressure on your spinal cord
and nerves
next your surgeon will remove the outer
layer of bone
metal rods or plates will be attached to
your vertebrae with screws
your surgeon may use some bone tissue
called a bone graft usually taken from
your hip bone
this bone graft material is placed along
your vertebrae these steps are done so
your vertebrae can grow together or fuse
your surgeon will close your skin
incision with sutures surgical skin glue
or staples your neck may be placed in a
collar to keep it still while your
vertebrae fuse
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring you'll
be given pain medication as needed you
may be released from the hospital within
two to three days after your procedure
you will wear your nut collar for
several weeks while your vertebrae fused
together